Betty is in Michigan with our question
she says our mortgage is their only debt
we have on paper in quotes we currently
have 19 years left to pay off the
mortgage but this does not reflect the
extra we have paid we recently checked
into refinancing to get lower payments
so we could throw more money at the
principal that's not necessary
I've written to not make it much of a
difference to do that so we chose not to
have you ever heard of recasting a
mortgage with the bank and my initial
investigation it looks convoluted
confusing and does not appear to have
much of an appositive effect on the
investor listen mortgages are calculated
as simple interest and so if you had
here's a simple way of looking at your
monthly interest rate is when it's
compounded and so if you have a 6%
mortgage that's 0.5 or half a percent a
month 6% a year
APR annual percentage rate and so
whatever your outstanding balance that
month is if you have a 6% mortgage is
charged a half a percent on that
regardless of when you paid extra where
are you whether it was a 30 whether it
was a 15 or the next month you pay extra
well the last month you paid extra if
you have a traditional conforming VA FHA
Fannie Mae conventional mortgage that's
how it's calculated now if you've got to
rip off mortgage of some kind with a
prepayment penalty a high interest rate
some kind of subprime crap then that's a
whole different ballgame
but your typical regular mortgage
recasting says I'm going to take my 10
year or my 19 year remaining balance and
we're gonna have them recast it reset
the mortgage like it's a 20 year all
that does is lower your payments because
you're gonna be in debt longer but the
interest charged will be exactly the
same except for that last year because
you stayed in debt longer it's that
simple
the more you pay on principle the next
month the more goes to principle because
every time you pay it down if
pay it down $10,000 if you paid down
$1000 or principal there's that much
less that's charged a half a percent the
next month so if you had a hundred
thousand dollar mortgage and you paid an
extra thousand dollars or you paid a
thousand dollars in principal the next
month the half a percentage is charged
on ninety nine thousand regardless of
how you did that principal as long as it
was applied the principal you just don't
want a prepay interest I paid my
payments for months and rents don't do
that
prepay principal and as long as you're
doing that recasting is not necessary on
paper is not necessary and you know if
you really want to kind of get real
nerdy and NIT see about it if you look
at your principal balance on your
amortization schedule you know the
little schedule that prints off will
used to print them off a hundred years
ago they were on green computer green
bar computer paper right back in the day
and they would have a column that is
your principal and interest payment then
the next column is how much of your of
it is interest the next column is how
much of it is principal and the next
column is the reducing principal balance
of the mortgage every month and so if it
says one hundred thousand on your
principal this month and you paid a
thousand dollars which was some extra
principal then you would just slide your
finger down until you find that ninety
nine thousand and that might be three
months from now four months from now
that it would have been had you paid
your regular payment and so if you
really want to go be nerdy about it
that's a way you can do it or you can
sit and recalculate it you can set up a
little spreadsheet to do it it's really
not that much because it's simple
interest as the interest is calculated
that month if it's compounded monthly on
the outstanding balance on the monthly
rate of interest and so that's all it is
it's a math formula and it's not you
know I've paid all the interest no you
didn't pay all the interest well the
first five years this mortgage was all
interest that's because your payment
consisted mainly of interest but you
weren't pre paying interest the interest
charged in those first five years was
the exact amount do you that month and
the different
rest of it in your payment was the exact
amount to the principal in order to
fully amateur eyes were fully pay it off
during the payment term of 30 years or
15 years or whatever it is so you do not
have to recast a mortgage to pay it off
early you have not wasted it if you
refinance it because you paid all the
interest on the front end you did not
pay all the interest on the front end
you paid the interest that was you that
was all you paid ever unless you have a
ripoff type mortgage